two words beachbod
zac efron hangs loose in costa rica
enjoying the surf and sand while showing
off those enviable abs
i'm in pretty good shape the 34 year old
actor flaunts his epic six-pack during a
jog on the beach before taking a sandy
stroll with some pals
showing off his personal washboard while
rocking blue swim trunks a dark baseball
cap and flip-flops
according to an eyewitness the star
snaps some shots of the seaside scenery
in between surf sessions
[Music]
but it's hardly the first time we've
seen a shirtless zack he's no stranger
to sharing a pick or two on the gram
keeping us all up to date on the results
of all that hard work in the gym
there's a lot of these you just don't
want to train you just have to get up
and and just like have that part of your
brain go get to it and and you roll out
of bed and i you know
i'm pretty
set up i have like a gym in my garage
but it's fun to push it to the limit you
know i show up in hair and makeup like
with instead of being just tired or just
waking up
i'm another sort of dead brain called
like runner's brain or post-training
brain i'm like
oh that's how i am too can't move my
legs
and his co-stars let's just say they're
inspired by his commitment
did you just uh look at my boobs i was
not my intention i didn't uh you look at
him right now his baywatch castmate
alexandra d'addario had this to say to
e.t after seeing her on-screen buddy's
lifeguard transformation
how many apps does he have more than i
thought was humanly possible right
because i checked it out i think it's
like a 12.
i don't know get the side abs
this is where it's at man everything's
happening the neighbor's actor loves
staying active so much that he launched
a digital series gym time in 2019.
15 reps and he literally turned into
brad pitt that wasn't there before you
got to work hard to
something else hard work hard to play
hard
that's it
and just a few months later zack gave
e.t an update on how those brad pitt abs
were coming along they're
never never going to be the quality of
brad pitts
those are those are does change the
world
i'm not looking to don't even mess with
them yet they're they're humbly
chilling exactly where they need to be
humbly chill
humbly chilling zach humbly and
respectfully we beg to differ
[Music]
you